la Oh God
yeah wasn't expecting this I'm gonna get
drunk I just oh my god no that's one of
the worst things I've ever tasted god I
did not think it was gonna be this drug
I would say 100% about a 0% felon
mmm cucumbers I don't like it but I
don't hate it when I bite it it feels
like I'm taking a shot yeah next up a
shot that doesn't end this is like if
you took vodka and made it crunchy
somehow here we go
berries the color of the strawberries is
very very scary it's like hey it's like
the ghost thing it's actually not that
bad it's maybe like a eight I was gonna
say eight - I'm gonna try blueberry now
Oh blueberry is completely fine you have
children and you want them to fall
asleep get a bunch of book America don't
do that
I'm getting drunken tomato I think this
is gonna make me taste like pizza Wow
like a like you dumped a bottle of vodka
and I peed
I actually surprised at how not bad oh
my god got better it got worse for me
the alcohol is not as strong in this
core this is a four out of ten
seven seven for me app are those up oh
wow these example our love's bro they do
not look appealing smells like somebody
tried to make an apple dog food oh this
is it a lot better it's still bad Oh
dope got much better way better much
better much more bearable fruitier I'd
rather enjoy my alcohol as I consumed it
I'd rather eat food out of the garbage
then eat this vodka food why did we
agree to this I know it sounded fun